-Welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome.
You guys look great.
Not only is this your first time
here, thank you for being here,
but for all of you,
this is your very first
late night talk show ever.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm honored.
The show "Reservation Dogs" has
gotten amazing accolades.
It's over 80 critics'
best-of-TV lists.
You won a Peabody Award.
You won a Gotham Award
for Breakthrough Series.
It's 98% on Rotten Tomatoes.
That's all great stuff.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to get into the show.
But I want to get to know a
little bit more about you guys.
D'Pharaoh, talk to me.
Were you always into acting?
Was that your plan?
-Um, not really.
I mean, when I was a little kid,
we used to --
me and my twin brother used to
make little skits here and there
but I never thought I could
actually do it
or be on a stage like here.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-And how did you hear
about the audition?
-Just like any other audition.
I got a self tape.
Really, what's interesting,
is in the final audition,
they brought us into this room,
and I seen how the camera was
just on a tripod right there.
And I know I had to do something
different, right?
And in the first episode, if you
guys have seen it, my character
is looking into the camera like,
"What's up, guys?"
So I took the camera,
I picked it up
and I pointed it to myself.
I'm like, "Yo, what's up?
These are my 'Rez Dog' friends."
And I showed
Taika and all of them.
They really got it
involved with my scene.
I think that's a big reason why
I got it.
-How did you get the guts to do
that in an audition?
-I don't know.
I had to do something different.
-And, Paulina, you wanted to be
an action star.
-Yes.
-Is that true?
-Yes, that's true.
-And I know that you are really
into sports.
Did you coach hockey
or you do coach hockey?
-Yes, I coached at a native
tournament called
Alberta Native Hockey
Provincials,
and I got to coach
the Alexis novice team.
And that was pretty fun.
Back home in my reserve,
we don't have a lot of
female hockey role models, so,
like, I get to be
a nice hockey role model
for my nieces and my nephews.
-Yeah, you didn't have that
as a kid?
-No, I didn't have that
growing up.
-Lane, you're still in school.
What do the other kids think
about all this?
You get treated differently?
Do you get special treatment?
-For the most part,
a lot of them don't know
or just don't care.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
That's kids for you. Yeah.
-I have a few friends
who they ask,
"What are you going to do
when you go back to school?"
And, like, "What are you going
to do about them?"
I'm just like, well, not really
telling many people about it.
A lot of people don't even know.
And some people who do know,
I just kind of stay quiet
about it.
-Yeah. Do people go, like,
"Well, you're acting
like your character?"
Because you kind of act like
your character.
-Yeah, I am -- I'm actually
pretty similar
to my character in,
like, many ways.
-He is, right?
-Not very different from him.
-Are all you guys kind of
similar to -- do you -- like,
you're very -- you've got
good, funny one-liners
you throw out there.
-That's what I love about
the show 'cause, like, we're all
basically playing themselves.
Like, they wanted rez kids,
they got rez kids.
So, yeah.
-That's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You did.
The show, can you set up
the show?
I don't know who is
the best to set it up
and tell everyone
what it's about.
If you haven't seen it,
it's on Hulu.
-"Reservation Dogs" is about
four native kids growing up
in a reservation and after they
lose their best friend,
they want to leave
the reservation.
But as the show goes on,
they learn just how
really special it is
and they come to love it
and not wanting to leave at all.
-Yeah. That's good. That's
a good way to describe it.
It's very funny.
It's very action-packed.
It's also very loving as well.
And I think it's getting great
attention for this great acting
and directing
and all that stuff.
But also it's a culture that
I don't know much about.
So I like seeing it and going,
"Oh, yeah"
and just going, "Oh, I want to
learn more about it."
Are there parts of the show that
you like better
than the other parts?
Do you like doing
the heist stuff?
Do you like doing the getting
in trouble stuff?
Do you like being funny?
Do you like the dramatic acting?
-I love all the funny stuff.
-Native people are so funny.
And like, it's the first time
it's ever been shown before.
-Yeah.
-So that's why I think a lot of
people are falling in love with
it, because it's our humor.
We're really funny people. It
just hasn't been shown before.
-Yeah. Good. I agree with you.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's a sneak peek of season
two of "Reservation Dogs."
Take a look.
-I'll have sacred duties.
-Who is he talking to?
-I think it's safe to say
he's delusional.
-Got to set a good example.
Help others.
-Uncle!
-What?
-The director's cut of
"Big Trouble in Little Ch--"
I've never seen this one.
-What the...are you kids
doing here?
-We need help.
-No.
You caught me right
in the middle of
making myself a better man.
-What's that mean?
-It means get the...out.
Okay? What the...are you
doing with that?
-It was in the trash.
-My mistake.
Leave me alone.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You have great chemistry.
You guys are so good.
The cast of "Reservation Dogs."
Season two premieres
this Wednesday on Hulu.